le long des autoroutes dans les stades
et même sur les tramways les ontariens
sont bombardés de publicités pour le
pari sportif
un déferlement qui se remarque encore
plus lorsqu'on allume la télévision
[Musique]
sur les chaînes sportives les publicités
se multiplient et le pari s'intègre même
à la couverture de certains journalistes
en avril l'ontario est devenue la
première province à libéraliser le
marché des jeux de hasard en ligne
depuis une vingtaine d'exploitants ont
obtenu des permis
espérazanaise
ça a été plus gros que cela qu'on
s'attendait confie sept représentants de
la province
l'objectif de la libéralisation était de
protéger les consommateurs explique
catherine germain en ce qui concerne les
publicités le gouvernement ontarien
promet d'avoir les compagnies à l'oeil
oui / non on y travaille mais il
n'existe aucune limite quant au nombre
de publicités qu'un opérateur peut
diffuser
qu'un boeing
les gens paris depuis le début de
l'humanité lance chely wright si elle
voit d'un bon oeil la légalisation du
jeu elles s'inquiètent de la
prolifération des publicités dose
cet expert est du même avis
j'aime la scène évolue dans le monde du
pari sportif depuis longtemps le pdg des
hippodromes houdbine veut aussi profiter
de cette révolution dans son industrie
everywhere
une chose est sûre la course aux
consommateurs et bien lancée et les
opérateurs se bousculent pour avoir un
morceau du gâteau le marché du pari
sportif en ontario et déjà évalué à plus
de 2 milliards de dollars un chiffre qui
risque d'augmenter dans les prochaines
années surtout si les joueurs sont plus
nombreux ici à celui des radio canada
toronto